so this is four years of college in
ping-pong balls I will be doing a BA in
theater um with a minor in musical
theater I'm studying psychology
you can't ever like really read people's
minds but it's as close as he can get to
it I chose political science because I
want to go to law school after I get my
bachelor's I have loved math all my life
so it was natural to choose that I know
that I have to take them out and you're
borrowing money from I guess it's some
unknown entity and then you're gonna
have to eventually pay it back I know
I'm gonna be paying the government but
I'm not exactly sure how the whole
payment process works what I do know is
that I already owe a lot of money to a
lot of different people
[Music]
I feel like Houdini
[Music]
wait this was one semester yeah this is
gonna be me
banana next year is this for four years
are we not done yet we're not done yet
[Music]
I don't like this
[Music]
there's more
so personal expenses laundry travel
clothing food that sort of thing
[Music]
[Music]
my face is itchy that was a lot so it's
four years of tuition and fees books and
room and board and then on top of all of
that you have a bucket full of interest
what's the button do
[Music]
[Music]
well that's better that's gone being in
the box was like this is my day I didn't
think about interested is something that
I am going to start thinking about being
able to click that red button and
release all that stress I need a lot of
red buttons in my life
[Music]